so you know there's this new term hostel
life you know it's been around for a
little bit and we think of all these
influencers and stuff but it sounds like
you I've been doing this for years in
terms of just going out there selling
stuff yourself we saw it a lot in the
music world especially back with with
CDs do you think filmmakers today have
enough of that hustle life in them or
they view it differently like I'm just
gonna give this to a distributor I made
my film
I spent whatever time with it three
years with it now I'm giving it to a
distributor they can take care of it and
is that a mistake to think like that no
it's not a mistake here's why I think I
think it depends on how much the
distributor gives you for your family
and we also have to keep in mind that
most distributors are not going to be
honest with us
so say for an official a hundred
thousand dollars in the distributor and
you give your you'll film away from free
like you have to be very careful and
make sure that an attorney looks over
all of your paperwork just don't give
your family you just can't give your
film away from free thinking that
distributor is gonna be honest with you
and gonna be cutting you a check so you
always have to leave room you always
have to leave room like if say for
instance if you make your film $400,000
if you decide okay I want to give just
to get your film out there I want to
give the the distributor the film just
to put out because I wanted to sit in
Walmart I want to sit on Netflix but if
you're not getting any money for it you
know you have to leave whereas you can
do theatrical or you can do DVD and you
can do streaming meaning that you know
you have to leave room so you can it's a
partnership if you want to take my
family okay you can take my famil but I
the hell I have to have the ability to -
we can do this together meaning that I'm
going to I'm going to distribute the
film as well you know you can take it to
whoever you want to take it to but you
know this is a partnership you have to
we have to we just can't give our fans
away to people so you know but if we do
give it away you know meaning no money
upfront then you have to have the bill
to make DVDs streaming on your own you
know in fight for they've made a
distributist if the distributor is
honest with you you know they'll give
you some money up front for your film
you know
but going back to the term hustle life
or whatever it is just just work ethic
do you think that artists have enough of
that in them know it here's the reason
why I think with the whole thing with
the streaming services now that people
will rather sit behind the computer and
just put it on on Amazon Prime because
there's no you can put on Amazon Prime
and you can market it on the your social
media and you'll have to do a lot of
hustle or you don't have to do a lot of
legwork I think that's a big mistake now
if you do put it on Amazon Prime what
you have to do is you have to still go
out still go out you have to go out to
events you have to have you some like
what we call the Chicago flyers or
pluggers and give it to people and make
sure people are actually going on Amazon
Prime because they're not gonna know it
it's on it even if if you have 5,000
followers one on on Facebook it's only
gonna reach about 20 people me that's
think that's the way they have it set up
so so you know but you can also spend a
couple of dollars with Facebook to to
promote it you know but go out and talk
to the people go out to these different
events every time an event is going on
well even a party is going on go out and
just give out progress or flyers you
have to market so we just did what for
black and priviledge behind why we did a
billboard if we have a billboard in the
angular community which is right off the
expressway so you have thousands of
people who are driving through in
essence big billboard you know so we
have to but you have to leave room for
marketing dollars and that's the thing
we don't do is that we don't leave that
room for marketing dollars so if you
raise $20,000 to shoot a family make
sure you're trying to liberate another
5,000 to market the film because worst
thing is you want people of people not
watching your family you know marketing
is very very very important when it
comes to our family
like marking it so I don't think that
filmmakers have that hustle that they
did back no you know no one like the
nineties in the early 2000 because of
the streaming services we want to sit
behind a computer to upload it and then
let it do what it do well no you have to
still do that legwork you know just like
if you drive down the different
Hollywood Boulevard you drive down la
downtown LA you still want to see
billboards you still want to see the
posters up because there somebody is out
there actually putting those posters up
you know and it doesn't take a lot of
money to do that well I mean on that and
that aspect yeah but we can still do
that doesn't it take us a lot of money
to put up a billboard so so there's a
company that you work with or that
you've worked with before to do the
Billboard and then what were you
advertising black and privileged for
like the screening or the just a movie
just oh just the movie there's a movie
so when people when people drive pass is
just a billboard
did you see you know what we remote the
movie beginning I think in his call for
getting several several marshals
yeah remember when I think it was like
ten years ago when that movie came out
and it was just like you saw the posters
all over the play was like what then
right I think I remember that yeah like
what is this you know I'm saying like
people want to know well it was just
forgetting sarah marshall like that
it was just like just the word some
people what's going on who's but you
know that's what I was thinking like
what's going on when is this happen and
so that's the same thing I want when I
was put the Billboard up when people
drive past and they see driving
privilege I wanna know what is this like
when is it coming out I want them to ask
questions because when they start asking
questions then not you in a conversation
with them you know and then and that's
what you want you want that conversation
so it wasn't even a direct call to
action for them to go to a certain site
or what it was just to pique their
curiosity jokes a subliminal you know
I've got no Drive past they say oh okay
and they always going to remember it so
say for instance if something comes up
on the social media or they go and they
google it and say cuz I'm sure a lot of
people are Google and say okay what can
I find is that you know because okay and
the title is a very catchy title and
Oh what can I find this you know so
that's what we our objective is to get
people online into Google the the black
a prevalence movie yeah
you